love your love I also love your home and
I've dying to get a tour
[Music]
I am obsessed with this room you're the
first person to get the reference and to
explain it I'm a huge Beetlejuice fan I
think what you did with the place it's
wonderful but this scene in the movie
used to scare the crap out of me yeah no
it was so scary
it's so great I just always think of it
in my head I always like I want a dining
room like that and can I may I I mean
you can I have to live my captain O'Hara
fantasy you know it comes down in the
closet if that happened right now I
would actually live we have to get a
bigger budget maybe we'll get that next
time listen all we need is a little
shrimp cocktail yes
thank you
at this table no Halloween I'm just
saying that's a Tick-Tock waiting to
happen yes you could be an ortho with
your hair
I thought you would never ask this is so
cool now what I didn't realize was that
your husband made these pieces yes he
designs Furniture he does interior
design and he said okay if you want a
Beetlejuice table he did it like he took
the screenshots did the edges and
everything exactly I mean so you guys do
have what like dinners here we have our
holiday dinners here this will be sold
with the house like you cannot get this
out we had to Crane it in it's so heavy
so it's gonna be sold with the house in
our bed too our bed is white marbled and
it's just so heavy you can't move it so
text me before you list it yeah come get
it I'm coming to get it yeah I'm gonna
live here just for this table alone
all right this is our like Casual Living
Room that turned into a playroom oh so
casual
this is where we spend most of our time
Malibu loves to be here she has her
chair her Slide the ball pit behind us
she spends the most times like this is
definitely Malibu's one of her spaces
too yeah so she say she grows up and she
tells you Mom I'm overpaying your
reaction's gonna be okay that'd be
ironic if Malibu where he starts liking
like dark emo but I'm there for it I'm
down for it we took her to emo day
recently see there you go I mean you're
wearing black today yeah come on yeah I
like balance okay so we're in the
kitchen but obviously my eyes went
directly over here to your bling
tumblers pride and joy right here do you
have a favorite I like all my custom
ones like I like the ones that are
custom this is my band's head boy 2005
this is my first podcast this is fresh
so I I like those custom ones that are
like you know they mean something but of
course driveway is Lena I'm like meet
Selena Selena okay Selena
oh
I can't okay
but wait there's more and there's you I
mean I have like Jewels I have Rolex
because I have Birkins these are my my
pride and joy if these got stolen my
heart would break everything else like
whatever so you you know how many you
have you know which ones you have oh
yeah we do inventory of it my husband
set this all up of course I love it okay
wait there's more bling though oh yeah
you see it the bling never ends so these
are actual condiments first of all like
I feel like the sauce is yeah you can
just refill them okay yeah well you know
what Beyonce said I got hot sauce in my
bag are you bringing this everywhere
yeah always some scrambled eggs
everything these are all my favorite
items and we do just refill them like
you actually use this yeah yeah those
are all things we actually use and
Trisha has plenty of places to use them
check out her second dining room decked
out in Versace I'm tripping because you
said this is where we have our casual
meal again nothing casual about this but
I'll go with it I love it I love it we
do fast food and target for other things
just balance it so we got the Versace
table but that's
yeah okay should we go upstairs yes
let's go to the rooms
[Music]
Trish I couldn't come to your home and
not see your closet yes this is my This
Is My Sanctuary this is my favorite this
is the first room Moses built for me and
I was like oh
is this your favorite room yeah I love
this this is like dress up I bring
Malibu in here she looks at all the
Sparkles she's like wow no I got a
question where does Moses put his
clothes he's in the other closet okay
that's not what it's how it came
originally I was like oh don't do it
every day he's like no I don't care okay
so this is just for you this is just my
closet yeah this is one and my main
closet's over there but this is my this
is my fancy closet my Skin's closet
[Music]
foreign
my favorite room I could tell why yes
Barbie everything and yeah I had so many
Malibu Barbies before she was even born
but then when she was born because I
gave him out of Barbies we had the Queen
Elizabeth ornament because everyone
thought she was The Reincarnation Queen
Elizabeth when she was born it was very
bizarre oh my God it is Malibu Barbie's
World and we're just living in it
exactly exactly this is her wardrobe and
we have most of these out
Halloween costumes or holiday costumes
first birthday is coming up so we have
that planned so this is all her special
costume she can come here and look in
the mirror herself which she loves to do
you want to see yourself who's that
pretty girl yeah
Malibu Barbie would you like to meditate
with us oh yes we have a meditation
Barbie should we go up to the meditation
room should we go and show them
[Music]
I feel like we have to go out and how
you go out in the meditation room yes
yes do those affirmations as like
[Music]
um I'll firm for you okay I am strong I
am successful I am worthy of this dream
job I get everything I want I'm so lucky
I am blessed I am thankful for all of
life's blessings I am worthy of
abundance I am open to receiving money
sticks to me love comes to me I am open
to receiving yes yes yes
um period
period laughs
[Music]